bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette édition de senna 360 tout de
suite
voici les titres une émission 100%
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
puisque dans un quart d'heure vous
pourrez suivre en intégralité cette
séance marquée par le retour d' edouard
philippe
au sénat le premier ministre qui avait
boycotté la semaine passée cet exercice
en signe de protestation après que le
sénat a transmis à la justice les cas
des proches conseillers de l'elysée dans
le cadre de son rapport sur la sphère
benalla ce sera aussi la dernière séance
de questions d'actualité pour nathalie
loiseau la ministre des affaires
européennes qui conduira la liste en
marche pour les élections européennes
les autres partis sont aussi en ordre de
marche
on en parlera dans cette édition et au
sénat
deuxième semaine d'examens pour la loi
mobilité avec au programme de cet après
midi la délicate question de la
limitation à 80 km/heure
les sénateurs veulent que les
départements ou les préfets et la main
pour réduire ou non la vitesse sur les
routes et tout au long de cette émission
vous pouvez réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag sénat 360 pour
m'accompagner cet après midi alexandre
poussard et dans les tribunes de
l'hémicycle et à mme tran huy
recueillera les réactions en salle des
conférences du sénat
et on parle justement rejoindre
alexandre poussard vous suivez pour nos
les travaux dans l'hémicycle et au menu
cet après midi dans le cadre de la loi
mobilité une question sensible
la limitation à 80 km/heure et oui
jérôme et le sénat vient de donner le
choix aux départements et aux préfets
d'abaisser ou non la vitesse à 80 km
heure sur les routes secondaires c'est
un moment est le fruit d'un long combat
de la droite sénatoriale contre la
décision du gouvernement d'expérimenter
de manière uniforme les 80 km heure sur
tout le territoire sur toutes les routes
secondaires
les sénateurs ont longtemps dénoncé un
manque de concertation une décision
éloigné des réalités il avait même créé
un groupe de travail sur les 80 km/heure
un groupe de travail qui avait demandé
au gouvernement d laisser le choix aux
territoires et cette demande n'avait pas
laissé insensible emmanuel macron qui au
mois de janvier dernier au début du
grand débat avait assuré qu'il y aurait
un réaménagement de cette mesure
une affirmation qui était bien tombé
dans l'oreille du sénateur les
républicains michel raison qui est le
chef de file de la droite sénatoriale
sur ces 80 km/heure et qui est l'auteur
de cet amendement
et vous allez le voir il a tenté de
convaincre la ministre des transports et
isabelle borne écouter leurs échanges
monsieur le président de la république a
fait appel aux maires pour faire des
propositions sur ce dossier qui fait
débat il a dit il faut ensemble que l'on
trouve une manière plus intelligente ce
de la mettre en oeuvre et c'est les
propos que j'avais tenu au premier
ministre que je les rencontre et que mes
collègues quand on a remis le rapport
une manière plus intelligente ne s'est
pas compliqué d'être plus intelligent
il est simple cet amendement est gelée
vraiment fait pour aider le président de
la république on donne simplement la
possibilité aux prêts aux présidents des
conseils départementaux de pouvoir
augmenter la vitesse
donc vous voyez madame la ministre je le
vois à votre air que vous allez être
favorable à mon amendement versa donc le
président de la république a eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur ce sujet le
premier ministre avait également annoncé
qu'il y aurait une évaluation des
dispositions mises en place et en
particulier du décret qui a conduit à
réduire la vitesse à 80 km heure sur les
routes bidirectionnelle donc dans la
tente à la fois de cette évaluation et
de contes conclusion du grand débat
proposent le retrait sinon avis
défavorable le gouvernement a donc
botter en touche en reportant de
quelques mois cette décision sur les 80
km/heure et malgré cet avis le sénat
dont bien adopté cet amendement et on
peut dire que sur cette question des 80
km heure le sénat a pris de vitesse le
gouvernement merci beaucoup alexandre et
on a entendu un michel raison dans votre
extrême ajustements va le rejoindre il
est aux côtés de tam traduit en salle
des conférences
effectivement à michel raison vient de
vous entendre dans cet extrait vous
attendiez que le gouvernement bouge sur
les 80 kilomètres à part ce que vous
avez senti emmanuel macron ouvert à des
aménagements pendant le grand débat mais
la ministre des transports n'est pas sur
cette ligne at il pour vous un double
discours entre président de la
république et le gouvernement bien
dysfonctionnements parce que si le
président de la république qui participe
à tous les grands débats
enfin s'il n'y a pas que celle-là de
promesses si incertain où il a fait une
promesse là dessus donc moi je veux
quasiment leur rendre service pour que
le président arrive à tenir ses
promesses semblerait que le premier
ministre ait fait des aménagements sur
les 90 l'adie de la différence j'ai
repris toutes ses phrases c'est formel
il l'a dit qu'il fallait appliquer cas
plus d'intelligence comme moi d'ailleurs
on est sur la même longueur d'onde je ne
suis pas contre la mise en place de 80
km heure sur un certain nombre de
tronçons
on est pour la mise en application avec
intelligence et surtout faisons un peu
plus confiance aux élus locaux puis
intelligence et donc de manière
décentralisée vous
lester la laisser la liberté aux
présidents de départements aux préfets
de relever la vitesse maximale de 80 à
90 parce que je suis quand même
extraordinaire c'est que l'état dit est
la décentralisation y compris dans la
désire comment expliquer aux qu'il
autorise un président de département
réduire la vitesse mais ils n'autorisent
pas augmenté c'est un manque de
confiance c'est pas des foulées
présidente conseils départementaux
ils n'ont pas non plus envie qui est des
morts sur les routes moi j'ai discuté
avec le maire n'est pas du même bord on
n'est pas toujours d'accord on est en
plein accord là-dessus et il est prêt à
faire des propositions est ce que pour
vous les 80 kilomètres n'ont pas
convaincu on a entendu le premier
ministre edouard philippe sarre valoir
une baisse historique des morts sur les
routes et la tribu à 80 km et là il a
sorti des chiffres mensongers jose jose
employer le terme peut mettre au
tribunal s'il veut il a comparé des
moyennes qui l'arrangé avec des chiffres
ponctuels donc le chiffre est faux
évidemment maintenant il n'ya pas de
deux
dessous de sursaut historique puisque
depuis plus d'un an on était en baisse
pour différentes raisons j'ignore
pourquoi d'ailleurs ont baissé on était
deux jours 90 et cette baisse s'est
poursuivie elle est en léger
ralentissement d'ailleurs mais cette
baisse se poursuit et c'est du bonheur
que cette et 80 bien sûr que non le
gouvernement également et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'a fait valoir la ministre
avait prévu de tirer un bilan détaillé
de la mesure après deux ans là on en est
à peu près à un an d'application vous ne
voulez pas laisser cette année
supplémentaire au gouvernement
alors je lui ai dit tout à l'heure je
considère que si impliqué mon amendement
on rend l'expérimentation encore plus
efficace parce qu'on aura des
départements qui vont rester
complètement 80 et des départements qui
vont oser remettre un certain nombre de
tronçons à 90 et là on aura encore une
plus belle expérimentations et bien
merci à beaucoup je vous en prie a
répondu à mes questions non plus merci
tam le président chinois xi jingping
poursuit sa visite officielle en france
après l'elysée ce matin où était
également convié un jean claude juncker
et un gala merkel il est arrivé au sénat
il ya quelques minutes au coeur de cette
rencontre sino françaises
l' équilibre des relations entre le
géant chinois et les européens emmanuel
macron a défendu les vertus du
multilatéralisme
on les écoute pour atteindre ces
objectifs c'est-à-dire un
multilatéralisme fort l'esprit de
coopération et ce nouveau lien d'
équilibre nous souhaitons pouvoir
avancer sur la construction d'un
multilatéralisme rénové alors nous avons
des divergences évidemment l'exercice de
la puissance dans l'histoire de
l'humanité ne va pas sans rivalité
nul d'entre nous n'est naïf mais nous
respectons la chine nous sommes
déterminés au dialogue et à la
coopération et nous entendons
naturellement de nos grands partenaires
qu'ils respectent aussi l'unité de
l'union européenne comme les valeurs
qu'elle porte pour elle même et dans le
monde est autour de ce respect des
souverainetés de la construction de ces
nouveaux équilibres et de la
construction d'un d'un cadre rénové et
loyal je crois que nous avons
ce président une chers amis le chemin
pour bâtir ce nouveau lien et on part
rejoindre tam traduit en salle des
conférences du sénat tom vous êtes avec
le sénateur de paris david assouline
pour évoquer une réforme du droit
d'auteur votée au parlement européen oui
effectivement david assouline votre
réaction à l'adoption de cette réforme
du droit d'auteur au niveau européen
cette réforme prévoit notamment que les
plateformes en ligne rémunère les
éditeurs de presse dont elle utilise les
contenus c'est un combat que vous aviez
portait aussi d'annoncer le rappel
oui mais c'est franchement un jour de
joie pour la création pour les créateurs
c'est un combat qui a duré des années
qui a eu beaucoup d'embûches face face à
lui les grosses plateformes ces grosses
plateformes intel etc ont fait un
lobbying mais je n'ai jamais vu ça ah
bon c'est historique
parce que c'est vrai que vous pouvez
essayer de légiférer de tâtonner au
niveau national mais les grandes
plateformes pouvaient contourner
elles ont même menacé l'espagne d'être
déréférencé à un moment donc la
puissance des tacons ces grandes
plateformes et bien exercer une pression
là au niveau européen enfin on peut
déployer un vrai rapport de force et
google ne peut pas se passer de 450
millions d'internautes et donc la loi
que j'ai fait passer en ce qui concerne
la presse c'est à dire le fait que les
éditeurs de presse puissent avoir des
revenus qui proviennent de leur travail
quand google ou des plateformes
utilisent ce travail elle a été adoptée
ici à l'unanimité par lequel les
éditeurs de presse sans être rémunéré
alors avant le mécanisme pour cette loi
soit adoptée vite parce que c'est ces
jeux moi j'ai eu la nouvelle
il ya quelques heures que ça va être mis
dans une la niche du modem à l'assemblée
nationale
ma loire doit être prise donc voyez il
ya unanimité ici là c'est le modem qui
est dans la majorité quand yann sohier
avoir d'éco-construction parfois peut y
avoir des co construction quand on est
ouvert et pas sectaires ça vient de moi
c'est pas pour ça que il faut le mettre
de côté et ça va permettre d'aller vite
parce que c'est début mai et donc ça
sera adopté à l'assemblée nationale
probablement début mais ensuite voilà
les les navettes rapides c'est quelque
chose qui peut peut être prêt à
appliquer cette directive européenne qui
a été votée là dès cet été
ce qui est incroyable en général on
attend je sais pas combien temps quand
il ya une directive
donc on a bien travaillé je suis très
heureux une petite question politique
pour inclure david assouline nathalie
loiseau a salué l'adoption de cette
directive
nathalie l'oiseau qui ne sera bientôt
plus ministre des affaires européennes
mais tête de liste pour les européennes
que pensez vous de cette liste qu'elle
porte qui ont cédé java 2 pascal canfin
à jérémy de serre donc de wwf à l'ex
président des jeunes agriculteurs
très franchement c'est j'attends que la
campagne comment je n'ai pas envie de
fustiger une liste pour le plaisir mais
si c'est pour soutenir
en gros la politique d' emmanuel macron
au niveau européen
je pense que c'est cette politique
libérale dérégulation qui fait le lit
qui accroît la puissance de ce qui est
notre ami principal à les nationalistes
et les populistes et donc je pense que
si on laissait ce face à face entre
cette politique là et les nationalistes
et les populistes et bien ce serait
catastrophique donc il c'est pour cela
que je soutiens une liste de gauche
démocratique écologistes j'aimerais que
touche quand s'unissent pour offrir
cette alternative bien merci à beaucoup
david assouline d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci tam et on vient de l'évoquer les
élections européennes c'est parti on
connaît désormais la totalité des têtes
de liste la république en marche dévoile
cet après midi sa liste complète les
socialistes espèrent un effet place
publique et les républicains se
rassemble derrière françois xavier
bellamy tour d'horizon au sénat de
l'état d'esprit avant cette élection
signé jonathan du prix yes
approché plusieurs fois sans succès
l'écologiste pascal canfin rejoint
officiellement la liste en marche aux
européennes en deuxième place derrière
nathalie loiseau une bonne nouvelle pour
andré gattolin sénateurs eux élevé
rallier au parti présidentiel
c'est quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
compétent son expérience mais aussi sa
jeunesse et sa connaissance du parlement
européen
d'anciens ministres est quelque chose de
très bien je trouve que ça fait un
binôme de liste avec nathalie d'oiseaux
tout à fait complémentaire et très
intéressant une belle prise pour l heure
où m
mais une nouvelle défection qui minent
les écologistes emmanuel macron souhaite
faire justement des prises sous être
verdir son image
parce que ce que je trouve juste c'est
que on fait pas en fait pas de la
politique en faisant des prisons fait de
la politique avec des avec des actes à
droite
légère embellie dans les sondages pour
françois-xavier bellamy sa liste est
désormais créditée de 12% d'intentions
de vote au départ critiqué pour sa
jeunesse et son inexpérience en
politique il redonne confiance à son
camp à mesure qu'il bat la campagne
c'est la fraîcheur c'est des idées
claires nettes et précises et les défend
et il s'investit pour effectivement le
mandat qui le oqali postule bellamy fait
sa campagne
il fait visiblement assez bien puisque
de tous les territoires et ici on est
sensible aux territoires
on n'a que de bons retours la gauche
aussi se lance dans la bataille pour la
première fois ensemble en déplacement à
creil raphaël glucksmann et olivier faur
veulent croire à un mouvement de bascule
mouvements difficiles à cerner pour
certains sénateurs ps
quand je vois qu'on était liste
uniquement socialiste on a 5 6% et
qu'avec glucksmann donc avec seulement
50% de socialistes
on est à 5 6% la joie juste une perte de
50% des lieux socialiste ne veut pas
pour l'instant le gain pour le parti
sioniste
à deux mois du scrutin européen les
principaux rôles semblent donc
distribués et les rues m et le
rassemblement national sont toujours au
coude à coude dans les sondages et on va
retrouver ta mme tran huy en salle des
conférences du sénat puisque tam vous
êtes avec la ministre des sports pour
évoquer cette polémique sur les propos
homophobes dans les tribunes des stades
de football notamment
oui la présidente de la ligue de foot
professionnel nathalie voie de la tour
juge que les chants de supporters
certains sont violents homophobes
séchant que vous dénoncez font partie du
folklore
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire si le
mot folklore veut dire l'histoire
l'histoire historique voir le passé oui
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec elle
puisque aujourd'hui dans notre société
il ya le mariage pour tous la
reconnaissance des personnes
homosexuelles et il n'y a aucune raison
que dans les stades sous couvert de
supportérisme on puisse dire des choses
qu'on n'a pas le droit de dire dans le
reste de la société
elle est défavorable aux sanctions
pénalité que vous réclamez ces sanctions
qu'elles seraient tels quels mécanismes
prévoyez-vous ça serait une sanction
pour les clubs
la présidente de la ligue est revenue
sur ses propos ce matin au moment de
nous avons réuni ensemble l'instance
nationale du supportérisme on est
revenue sur ces sujets effectivement
nous sommes tout à fait en phase sur la
phase d'éducation de prévention qu'il
faut avoir à l'égard des supporters mais
surtout ce qui est sanction je crois que
ça passera par la responsabilisation des
clubs comme cela est fait pour les
propos racistes antisémites ou voilà sur
sur toutes les dérives qu'on peut
regarder dans le football est observée
mais effectivement cette cette partie la
sanction est importante aussi parce
qu'il n'y a que comme ça qu'on va
pouvoir mettre les supporters les
associations de supporters devant leur
devoir est aussi derrière on espère
devant leurs droits parce que le
supportérisme c'est un élément important
du sport de l'accompagnement de la
mobilisation du public pour le spectacle
sportif et pour le résultat sportif et
on a aussi envie d'accompagner ce
mouvement de parce qu'aujourd'hui les
supporters méritent beaucoup plus que ce
qu'ils n'ont bien merci à beaucoup
roxana maracineanu d'avoir répondu à mes
questions alors que la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
vient de débuter et on prend tout de
suite la direction de l'hémicycle
la parole est à madame sylvie robert
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
merci merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
tout d'abord permettez moi de vous dire
combien nous sommes ravis de vous
retrouver dans notre hémicycle
ma question porte sur un sujet déjà
évoqué ici
la hausse des frais d'inscription des
étudiants extra communautaires et qui
aujourd'hui plus encore qu'hier suscite
de grandes interrogations voire le rejet
de beaucoup d'acteurs concernés au
premier rang desquels les présidents
d'université cette décision prise sans
aucune concertation et dans la plus
grande précipitation n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune étude d'impact
tout comme le plan bienvenue à en france
qui certes contient des éléments
positifs mais qui aurait aussi mérité
d'être plus concertée je pense notamment
aux collectivités territoriales
augmenter les frais d'inscription pour
les étudiants étrangers n'est pas une
mesure technique
c'est un acte profondément politique aux
conséquences potentiellement lourdes
pour la france et sur ce qui fait la
france parce qu'il touche aux conditions
d'accès à l'enseignement supérieur
parce qu'il touche aux ressources et au
financement de nos universités
parce qu'il touche enfin à notre
diplomatie d'influencé et culturelles et
singulièrement la francophonie
c'est une question fondamentale qui
méritait mieux que de prendre à la hâte
une telle mesure
on sait les textes réglementaires prêts
à les accepter vous acceptez vous de les
suspendre pour prendre le temps de
définir une vraie stratégie
d'attractivité internationale que vous
avez vous lu monsieur le premier
ministre et acceptez vous ce moratoire
comme l'a d'ailleurs préconisé la
commission culture et éducation du sénat
merci madame rover la parole est à vrm
frédéric lui
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
de la recherche et de l'innovation
madame merci madame la présidente mme
elham et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs modem la sénatrice sylvie
robert vous avez raison c'est une
décision éminemment politique c'est la
première fois qu'un gouvernement décide
de faire de l'attractivité des
universités un sujet et c'est pourquoi
nous avons travaillé d'abord à préparer
ce plan bienvenue en france qui
rappellent qu'ils vous l'avez rappelé
aux comporte plusieurs phases
une facilitation pour l'arrivée des
étudiants à meilleur accueil la
possibilité aussi de soutenir le
développement de formations françaises à
l'international
la concertation a eu lieu elle a duré
plusieurs semaines elle a d'ailleurs
donné lieu à des annonces qui font
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble des doctorants
ne seront pas concernés par ces mesures
et les exonérations dont les universités
disposent leur permet de préparer la
montée en puissance de ce plan
d'attractivité de façon à ce que les
étudiants internationaux qui sont en
capacité de financer leurs études et ils
sont nombreux en france inscrits dans
les écoles notamment
eh bien ces étudiants puissent permettre
par un principe redistributif de
financer correctement les étudiants
internationaux qui eux ont toutes les
capacités pour réussir mais qui
malheureusement parce qu'ils sont
obligés de travailler à côté de leurs
études ne peuvent pas le faire
c'est donc vingt-et-une mille bourses et
exonérations qui vont être mis à la
disposition des postes majoritairement
dans les pays d'afrique francophone pour
soutenir l'attractivité envers ces pays
mais c'est aussi une politique très
volontariste d'amélioration de l'accueil
des étudiants internationaux et ça aussi
ça soutient la francophonie j'étais il
ya quelques jours au kenya en ethiopie
en chine
est ce que les étudiants qui ont fait
leurs études en france m'indique c'est
que la qualité de l'accueil n'est pas à
la hauteur de la qualité des formations
c'est à cela que nous devons remédier je
vous remercie
merci madame laminé
str madame robert vous avez 20 secondes
pour la réplique
je voulais simplement dire un même
disque que la politique d'exonération
n'est pas est une vision court termiste
car elle ne réglera pas la question est
la règle rap et est cette année mais on
sait très bien que ça va être un
problème
les années prochaines je crois que cette
mesure heurte profondément notre
tradition d'hospitalité et d'ouverture
est considéré aujourd'hui les et les
étrangers plus comme une charge que
comme une chance je crois que c'est en
tout cas très regrettable pour tout le
monde est en tout cas notre pays
aujourd'hui merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur joël guerriau
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
immersion dans la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous saluons la présence du
président chinois qui achève sa tournée
européenne en france cela présente une
avancée dans les échanges entre nos deux
pays
monsieur çi jingping s'est d'abord
rendue en italie le gouvernement italien
a choisi de rejoindre les nouvelles
routes de la soie
toutes les routes ne mèneront plus à
rome mais à pékin
monsieur çi est ensuite allé à monaco
une fois n'est pas coutume la riche
principauté a accepté d'aider un état
communiste le rocher s'apprête à
accueillir la technologie 5g huawei sur
laquelle pèsent de lourds soupçons
d'espionnage après l'avoir utilisé le
gouvernement américain a pris la
décision d'interdire cette société la
chine pratique un espionnage massif y
compris par le biais de ses entreprises
qui doivent depuis une loi de 2010 est
contribuer aux renseignements bien que
la chine fait la deux le deuxième
partenaire commercial de l'union
européenne ils sont il subsiste des
divergences fondamentales notamment sur
le plan des libertés individuelles ou
encore sur celui du droit international
pouvons-nous accepter que l' empire du
milieu prennent le contrôle de la mer
méridionale de chine au détriment de ses
voisins
il est également regrettable que pékin
fasse pression pour empêcher taiwan
d'intégrer le m s alors que la santé est
un droit humain fondamental
nous devons donc être vigilant
tous aux intentions chinoises en matière
de politique étrangère mais aussi
commerciale la 5g chinoise ressemble à
s'y méprendre au cheval de troie faut-il
que le ouvrions nos portes
la commission européenne doit présenter
sous 15 jours
une position concertée à propos de la
cyber sécurité des réseaux 5 g monsieur
le ministre quelle sera la position de
la france sur ce sujet merci la parole
est à monsieur jean baptiste lemoyne
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
merci beaucoup mr le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur joël guerriau effectivement la
visite du président chine poursuit et en
ce moment même dans les murs du sénat
c'est une un moment important un temps
fort puisque vous le savez nous
célébrons cette année le 55e
anniversaire de l'établissement des
relations diplomatiques entre nos deux
pays
ce fut une visite préparée naturellement
avec un très grand soin avec une très
grande exigence et qui a permis je crois
de réaffirmer que face à des grands
défis mondiaux communs notamment
climatiques par exemple eh bien nous
avons des responsabilités communes
ce que je constate c'est que après un
peu plus de deux jours cette visite a
été empreinte de respect d'amitié sans
pour autant laisser cours à la naïveté
c'est une réussite pour la relation
bilatérale avec une commande de 300
airbus mais également le renforcement de
la coopération culturelle de la mobilité
de nos jeunes de la formation
professionnelle ou des échanges
linguistiques et le président de la
république a également rappelé les
préoccupations qui sont les nôtres et
celle de l'europe sur la question des
droits fondamentaux
ce matin avait lieu d'ailleurs un moment
très important un moment où s'agissant
de rénover le multilatéralisme qui vous
le savez parfois battus en brèche par
certaines puissances et bien l'europe
était présente à travers le président de
la commission européenne à travers la
chancelière merkel le président de la
république et mène macron aux côtés du
président chi pour affirmer un certain
nombre est bien
d'engagement pour que ce
multilatéralisme soit toujours vivace
tout cela se fait dans un moment où
l'europe elle même est bien est en train
de revoir un certain nombre de ses
cadres d'intervention et de ses cadres
tout simplement de coopération notamment
en matière commerciale en matière
économique
il s'agit il s'agit s'agissant de nos
industries stratégiques nos industries
sensibles de nous doter d'un cadre
protecteur sans discrimination mais
d'ailleurs nos amis chinois font de même
il est important et bien de s'engager
également cette voie là mais aujourd'hui
c'est la coopération qui s'est exprimé
et c'est heureux merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur bériault il vous reste
en seconde pour la réplique
bah écoutez j'ai pas reprendre la
question puisque j'ai pas eu de réponse
j'aurais vraiment aux yeux
j'aurais souhaité avoir une réponse sur
la question derouet et surtout sur
toutes les questions qui touchent nos
réseaux informatiques et notre
dépendance de plus en plus fort dans des
domaines où la stratégie a aussi sa
place et c'est là à mon avis sur le plan
européen une question que nous devons
traiter de manière sérieuse merci merci
chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur laurent duplomb
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la prime madame la présidente
ma question est pour monsieur le premier
ministre
souvenez vous le 14 novembre je
commençais ma question par la discussion
de colbert à mazarin sur le défaut bien
français de toujours taxer imposé
contraindre fiscalement à la fin je vous
prévenait de ne pas faire la même erreur
que marie antoinette en n'entendant pas
la colère monte je ne pensais pas si
bien dire au vu des émeutes qui ont
suivi
n'oublions pas que les premières
revendications de ces manifestations
était arrêté de nous taxer
laissez nous vivre de notre travail par
une pirouette intelligente vous avez mis
en place votre grand débat bel écran de
fumée qui par sa durée les interventions
dithyrambique du président ont fait
oublier le corps du sujet qu'elle n'a
pas été mon étonnement en lisant les
propositions du parti majoritaire et de
vos ministres avec toujours plus de
taxes et d'impôts augmentation des
droits de succession taxation des plus
values sur les résidences principales
retour de la taxe carbone alors monsieur
le premier ministre
quand allez vous enfin comprendre qu'il
faut sortir de cette addiction à l'impôt
pouvez vous vous engagez aujourd'hui à
ne crée ni augmenter aucun impôt mais si
monsieur du plomb la parole et à
monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics féministe madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur nous partageons
point de vue qu'avec impôts il faut
utiliser un verbe les baisser monsieur
le sénateur nous sommes tout à fait
favorables à votre proposition c'est
d'autant plus vrai que vous aurez
constaté ce matin que pour la première
fois depuis bien longtemps
l'insee ici même plusieurs fois les
sénateurs et les sénatrices à forte
raison aux mille le gouvernement devant
des contradictions avec les chiffres cas
divulguer l'insee que nous n'avons
jamais contesté l'insee a dit d'une part
que nous sommes le gouvernement qu'avant
le plus baissé les impôts depuis
désormais 15 ans dans les deux premières
années notre mandat nous sommes le
gouvernement qui avons baissé en volume
ce qui n'a pas existé depuis plus de 20
ans la dépense publique
nous sommes le gouvernement qui avons
pour la troisième fois de suite puis à
déficit en dessous de 3% je rappellerai
que lorsque nous sommes arrivés en
responsabilité le déficit était de 3 4%
il baisse désormais de 1 points pour
être à 2 5%
et malgré tous les prophètes de malheur
nous avons la croissance la plus élevée
de l'union européenne et nous avons
terminé l'année 2018 avec une croissance
à 1,6 pour cent
il est vrai monsieur le sénateur il est
vrai monsieur le sénateur que pour
baisser les impôts il faut baisser la
dépense et de ce point de vue et de ce
point de vue il ya beaucoup de croyants
mais peu de pratiquants puisque lorsque
nous proposons de baisser la dépense et
singulièrement à la majorité sénatoriale
dans le détail nous avons quelques
quiproquos
je n'ai pas attendu monsieur le sénateur
de la part du chef de votre partie des
propositions claires de baisse de la
dépense publique bien au contraire
alors oui notre pays doit abaisser
encore plus ses impôts c'est ce que nous
faisons sur l'impôt sur les sociétés sur
la taxe sur l'habitation évidemment sur
tout impôt qui demain pourraient grévé
notre économie le premier travail sur
les impôts de production et nous vous
demandons s'il vous plaît de faire une
revue de détail dites-nous si c'est
possible
là où vous souhaitez vous baisser la
dépense publique je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur du plomb pour la réplique
vous avez 30 secondes les chais du plan
l'exemple que vient de donner monsieur
darmana monsieur le premier ministre est
exactement le vrai exemple
l'exemple que l'on ne peut pas se
féliciter malgré ce qu'il dit des
résultats avec 76 milliards de déficit
en 2018 alors que l'allemagne compte à
beldi comptabilise 50 9 milliards avec
une dette de 2300 milliards alors que
l'allemagne passe en dessous des 60 %
avec 65 milliards déficit sur la balance
commerciale alors que l'allemagne fait
228 milliards d'excédents le général de
gaulle disait quand je me regarde je me
désole mais quand je me compare je me
console
si la première partie de sa phrase
relate bien la situation de la france la
deuxième partie absolument pas alors
monsieur le premier ministre si vous
voulez enfin vous consoler agissez
agissez vite fait des économies et
arrêter de penser qu'à puiser dans la
bourse des français merci chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean françois
longeot pour le groupe union centriste
mais selon zhu à vous la parole
madame meurt alors madame la présidente
monsieur le président ce tracé
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre la cohésion des territoires et
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre le 17 juillet 2010
est le prétendant république fixait pour
objectif le déploiement sur l'ensemble
du territoire du haut débit d'ici 2020
ainsi que du très haut débit d'ici 2022
or la semaine dernière une enquête de
l'association ufc que choisir estime ecc
6 et 8 millions de français étaient
toujours privés d'un accès de qualité
minimales à internet
cela représente 10,1 pour cent de la
population
quant au haut débit ce sont près de 12 8
millions de français qui en sont
aujourd'hui privés soit 19 8% de la
population au delà de ces chiffres
il s'agit de se rendre compte des
importantes disparités territoriales la
même association distinguer alors deux
france celle des villes de plus de 10
mille habitants ou plus de 95 % des
habitants ont accès à internet et celle
des villages de moins de 1000 habitants
où cette proportion baisse à 69 %
madame ministre sentiment de recul des
services publics des déserts médicaux
certaines zones rurales doivent
également affronter les effets d'une
fracture numérique insupportable à
l'heure où la transformation numérique
est le corollaire indispensable la
transformation de l'action publique
le risque est bien celui d'une des
incarnations de l'administration dans
ces territoires isolés numériquement où
en sommes-nous madame la ministre du
plan d'action en matière de couverture
numérique censé assurer une couverture
en très haut débit sur l'ensemble du
territoire
pouvez vous nous préciser le calendrier
concernant la réouverture du guichet
fonds pour la société numérique alors
que les collectivités territoriales
avaient misé sur ce guichet pour
accélérer le déploiement de la fibre
optique je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole à madame la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
ddt et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales à mon bureau
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean-françois longs jours vous
avez rappelé les objectifs du
gouvernement d'ici 2020 et de 6 et 2022
je voulais vous préciser qu'avec le
premier ministre nous sommes rendus dans
le gers vendredi et nous avons fait le
point sur l'avancée des chantiers et
dans un département rural comme le gers
avec un habitat très dispersé
on voit combien les chantiers avancent
et je voudrais bien sûr félicité les
élus du gers qui avec l'état ont fini on
finançait le déploiement bien sûr à la
fois du réseau mobile est à la fois du
réseau numérique le premier ministre
d'ailleurs il a annoncé le déblocage de
243 millions pour huit réseaux
d'initiative publique
répartie sur neuf départements
s'agissant de la couverture mobile ou
connaissent l accord que nous avons
passé avec les opérateurs et avec sous
contrôle de l'arcep et les résultats
sont là
la couverture 4g a porté par les quatre
opérateurs de téléphonie mobile a
progressé mais selon joe de 45% en 2018
avec plus de 4000 pylônes existants qui
ont été équipés de 4 g et ce déploiement
se poursuit évidemment en 2019 avec
cette fois des créations de sites
mobiles nouveaux qui ont été d'ailleurs
décidé avec les collectivités
territoriales
s'agissant de la couverture en internet
fixe les déploiements progresse partout
en france pour cette année trois
millions 3,2 millions très exactement de
locaux ont été raccordés à la fibre
optique tant en zone rurale qu'en zone
urbaine le soutien de l'état aux réseaux
d'initiative publique se poursuit dans
le cadre du plan très haut débit je vous
rappelle que l'état a mis 3 milliards
3 d'euros puis je voulais vous dire
conclure que nous avons aussi le projet
de cohésion numérique des territoires
c'est à dire pour les dernières maisons
où le numérique ne veut pas arriver il y
à une aide allant jusqu'à 150 euros pour
recevoir internet par voie hertzienne
merci madame la ministre que l'on joue
très bien mais parle à notre collègue
dominique théophile pour le groupe de la
république en marche vous avez la parole
mon cher collègue monsieur le président
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre nous avons été
nombreux en outre-mer à apprendre par
voie de presse une volonté du
gouvernement de revisiter le mode
opératoire des congés bonifiés au profit
des fonctionnaires ultramarins affectés
dans l'hexagone les congés bonifiés des
fonctionnaires ultramarins sont
considérées comme un avantage social
acquis après de dures et longues
batailles
ainsi tous les fonctionnaires
originaires d outre-mer peuvent
actuellement prétendent tous les trois
ans à ces congés qui peuvent s'étaler
jusqu'à 65 jours d'affilée dans 35 jours
de bonification pour rejoindre leurs
familles et leurs proches
ces congés peuvent être octroyées après
36 mois consécutif de service les
fonctionnaires bénéficient en plus d'une
prise en charge de l'eau fred à vias
d'avion est une prime de vie chère tout
au long de leur résidence et sur leur
territoire d'origine
cette réforme devrait entrer en vigueur
à partir de 2020 auquel cas c'est congé
serait moins long mais pourrait être
octroyée tous les deux ans au lieu de
trois de plus une politique en faveur de
la réduction du coût des billets sur la
mise en place une concertation entre les
différents employeurs publics et les
organisations syndicales sur cette
réforme devrait avoir lieu prochainement
il semblerait que le gouvernement
veuille aboutir à des textes
réglementaires d'ici l'été 2010 9 fixant
les nouvelles normes applicables en 2020
aux fonctionnaires ultramarins inquiète
la délégation aux outremers de
l'assemblée nationale à charge et david
lorion député de la réunion de rapports
sur cette réforme annoncée en
conséquence
ma question sera la suivante pour éviter
toute forme d'interprétation pouvez vous
nous décrire en détail le contenu de
cette réforme et son calendrier pour
vous répondre la parole et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics monsieur du shop
vous avez la parole monsieur minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur théophile leur son discours en
guyane à l'ouverture des assises de
l'outre-mer le 28 octobre 2017
le président de la république avait
annoncé une réforme des congés bonifiés
dans le cadre de la restitution de ces
mêmes assises le 28 juin 2018 il a
confirmé son intention en annonçant une
réforme du dispositif qui je le cite
sera effective à compter de 2020
pour ceux qui sont fonctionnaires avec
un objectif simple un principe simple
les congés seront moins long mais
désormais tous les deux ans c'est avec
cet objectif en tête que le gouvernement
souhaite comme vous l'avez noté qu'une
concertation associant les organisations
syndicales représentatives et les
employeurs des trois versants de la
fonction publique soit organisée avant
l'été pour cette comtesse cette
concertation pardon puisse permettre
d'évaluer le dispositif dont les
caractéristiques actuelles ont été
déterminants 1978 et le cas échéant
identifier les évolutions pertinente de
ce dispositif
en toute hypothèse et j'insiste sur ce
point conformément aux annonces du
président de la république
les travaux seront conduits non pas pour
remettre en cause le droit aux congés
bonifiés
mais pour en mode à moderniser les
modalités d'application de façon à
permettre aux bénéficiaires de
bénéficier de congés plus fréquents tout
en répondant aux enjeux d'efficacité est
continuité des services publics
le régime actuel des congés bonifiés net
en réalité plus adaptée ni à notre temps
ni à nos modes de transport ni même à
nos modes de congé et il mérite d'être
revu
nous souhaitons une politique qui incite
à revenir plus vite plus facilement plus
souvent et moins longtemps
comme l'a annoncé le président de la
république ainsi nous souhaitons qu'au
lieu de partir tous les trois ans comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui et vous l'avez
rappelé les agents publics de l'hexagone
qui ont leurs intérêts matériels et
moraux dans les territoires d'outre-mer
puisse partir tous les deux ans avec
leur famille et ce dès l'année 2020 et
donc pour celles et ceux qui ont
bénéficié de ce système en 2018 cela
permettra de démontrer la rapidité de la
nouvelle rotation
par ailleurs le congé supplémentaire de
35 jours qui perdurait pour des raisons
historiques ne se justifie plus
aujourd'hui et seuls les temps de
transport réel devront être accordés
j'ai pris des choses monsieur présidence
ou si vous le permettez la première
produire que la réforme des congés
bonifiés n'entraîne pas de réforme de la
question des surrémunérations et la
seconde pour confirmer ce que vous avez
dit nous souhaitons diminuer le prix des
transports
n'en trouvant une solution souple en
lien avec les compagnies aériennes pour
ne pas mettre à la charge des
bénéficiaires
une charge qui serait très bien pourquoi
encore vraiment ce qu'ils ont pu
quelques secondes
oui ça devient plus clair il ce qui
serait souhaitable c'est que les
parlementaires ultramarins soient
associés à la discussion
merci la parole est notre collègue
franck menonville pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
la parole monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur ministre de l'éducation
nationale ga ceci mon collègue gérard
longuet elle porte sur la place réservée
à la bataille de verdun dans les
nouveaux programmes scolaires suite aux
débats passionnés de ces derniers jours
trois cent mille morts 400 mille blessés
dix mois de combats plus de 60 millions
d'obus par son ampleur la bataille de
verna est l'une des plus emblématiques
de la première guerre mondiale
monsieur le ministre si vous avez
réaffirmé que la bataille de verdun
continuera bien être étudié en cours
d'histoire par les élèves de première
nous souhaitons qu'elles soient plus
explicitement nommées dans lé bulletin
officiel de l'éducation nationale au
même titre que la bataille de la somme
verdun est un symbole de la grande
guerre a au lieu de l'histoire où tant
d'hommes se sont sacrifiés les nouvelles
générations viennent en nombre sur ce
site chaque année le champ de bataille
de verdun porte encore les stigmates de
l'horreur cette zone rouge d'environ
quinze mille hectares au paysage d'y
figurer
où reposent encore plus de cent mille
soldats et les vestiges de neuf villages
détruits reconnu morts pour la france
témoigne de
de l'enfer de verdun mais verdun est
aujourd'hui devenue la capitale mondiale
de la paix le symbole de l'amitié franco
allemande
en atteste et on l'illustrent la poignée
de main historique de 1984 entre helmut
kohl et françois mitterrand plus
dernièrement la langue est la mère
qu'elle est françois hollande en 2016 au
lendemain de la commémoration du
centenaire de la grande guerre et à
quelques semaines des élections
européennes il mieux l'ensemble
nécessaire de ceux de le souligner
monsieur le ministre monsieur miss
verdun porte un message d'universalité
contemporain qui doit absolument être
transmis à notre jeunesse
si tous nous pouvons faire confiance à
l'appréciation de nos professeurs
pouvez-vous malgré tout nous rassurer
quant à son inscription officielle dans
les programmes scolaires pour vous
répondre la parole est à mme x glide de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
fort deux minutes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur frank mais non ville je peux
évidemment vous rassurer et vous
rassurer fortement je commencerai par
vous dire dès que mon grand père s'est
battu à verdun probablement comme
beaucoup de détails et d ieu de
personnes ici présentes et je n'ai pas
plus de raisons que vous de souhaiter
que verdun soit occultée et verdun je le
dis très solennellement n'est aucunement
occulter par les programmes que nous
avons conçu verdun n'est pas occulté
parce que non seulement verdun n'est pas
occulté mais verdun progresse si vous me
permettez l'expression
puisque dans les programmes qui
existaient précédemment verdun n'était
pas nommé c'étaient les programmes de
2010 s'il n'était pas nommé la première
guerre mondiale elle même n'était pas
réellement explicité puisqu'elle était
là simplement à titre d'exemple de ce
qui était une guerre totale absolue
les nouveaux programmes sont
incontestablement un progrès à cet égard
et à bien d'autres puisque ils sont
chronologique et donc on étudie la
première guerre mondiale de façon
chronologique
après ce qui s'est passé avant et avant
ce qui se passera après eh bien
l'élève de troisième étudie verdun déjà
c'est dans les programmes aussi en
première ils leur et étudie de nouveau
au travers de ces programmes
chronologique qui établissent qu'on est
con on étudie non seulement la guerre de
14 18 mai à l'intérieur de la guerre de
14-18 la guerre de position et si on
parle de guerre de position on parle
évidemment de verdun verdun sera donc
étudié verdun sera analysée verdun sera
approfondie non seulement au titre de
l'histoire
mais d'ailleurs aussi au titre de la
mémoire ir même c'est un hasard du
calendrier si je puis dire se tenait un
colloque de l'éducation nationale sur la
façon dont nous avons commémoré le
premier centenaire est donc tout ce que
vous avez dit j'y souscris évidemment
c'est à dire que nous avons aussi à
montrer verdun non seulement de 14 mai
le verdun de mémoire et bien sûr je
garantis que les documents
d'accompagnement qui sont au moins aussi
important que ce que nous écrivons dans
les programmes parleront de verdun enfin
vous l'avons dit vous l'avez dit nous
pouvons faire confiance aux professeurs
n'y a pas un professeur
d'histoire-géographie en france qui
parlerait de la guerre de 14 18 sans
parler de verdun alors si vous voulez ce
week-end j'ai entendu des choses parfois
qui m'ont surpris j'ai entendu certains
dire que c'était la deuxième mort de
verdun pour moi verdun n'est pas mort
c'est là il ya une première victoire et
si la mémoire est une victoire et bien
justement une deuxième victoire de
verdun la parole est pas notre collègue
michel rhéaume pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
ces derniers mois et encore plus ces
dernières semaines les annonces sur la
question des retraites se multiplient et
se contredisent à l'évidence en matière
de déclaration et de promesses
gouvernementales
le principe de précaution s'impose comme
le dit le bon sens populaire quand c'est
flou il ya un loup
dernière annonce en date
l'assouplissement du cumul
emploi-retraite permettant retraité de
continuer à travailler afin d'obtenir
des points supplémentaires pour leur
trop faible pension
c'est aberrant dans un contexte de
chômage de masse de révolution numérique
qui appelle une réduction du temps de
travail et d'une espérance de vie en
bonne santé bien en dessous de la
moyenne européenne
en effet va falloir travailler plus
longtemps car le système de retraite par
points que vous voulez mettre en place
va conduire à une baisse des pensions de
retraite qui impactera particulièrement
les ouvriers et les femmes dans ces
conditions il faudra bien travailler
plus pour s'assurer des revenus décents
vous continuez les annonces dans le plus
grand flou et fait fi des concertations
en cours avec les partenaires sociaux
mais une chose est sûre les français en
ont assez de voir leurs droits attaqué
sous des prétextes financiers c'est
d'ailleurs ce que révèle un sondage
récent de l'institut harris selon lequel
presque deux tiers des français sont
opposés à un allongement de la durée de
cotisation et au report de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite
nous savons ce que pensent les français
peut-on enfin savoir comment se
positionne le gouvernement et quels sont
ses réelles ambitions concernant les
retraites
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
aux prises des solidarités van hamme du
buzz j'avais la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur sénateurs manas matrix le jeu
l'objectif de la réforme des retraites
est clair il s'agit de construire un
système de retraites plus lisible plus
juste plus solidaire qui donne les mêmes
droits à tous un euro cotisé pour le
même droit à système où les règles sont
les mêmes pour tous c'est le mandat qui
a été donné à jean paul delevoye
comme l'a rappelé le ministre marc
fesneau la semaine dernière ce mandat
n'a pas changé et ne porte pas sur la
question de l'âge minimal de départ à la
retraite
dans le même temps examinons les faits
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie est
une réalité que nous devons regarder en
face aujourd'hui en france les personnes
de plus de 85 ans sont 1,5 million elles
seront cinq millions en 2020 il s'agit
là d'un changement démographique
ma
heures comme il y en a peu dans
l'histoire des sociétés le
vieillissement de la population induit
représente un défi majeur pour notre
protection sociale et son financement
notamment pour notre système de santé et
de prise en charge des personnes âgées
dépendantes
il nous faudra déployer des moyens
financiers considérables pour répondre
aux attentes des français pour baisser
le reste à charge des familles et enfin
améliorer les conditions de travail
notamment dans les ehpad
nous avons pris un engagement celui de
départ en toute transparence sur la mise
en place d'un système universel de prise
en charge des retraites sans remettre en
cause les plages légal de départ mais
aussi sur l'accompagnement de la perte
d'autonomie en s'interrogeant le cas
échéant sur une forme d'augmentation du
temps de travail je vous remercie vous
prétendez que l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite ne sera pas modifié mais pouvez
vous continuer à affirmer que les
travailleurs pourront toujours partir à
taux plein à 62 ans alors que tout le
monde que votre objectif inavoué c'est
bien le recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jean pierre vogel dans le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur le ministre si
j'en juge par vos déclarations vous
souhaitez faire de la reconquête
industrielle votre priorité vous avez
récemment déclaré dans le journal les
échos que vous vous battrez pour chaque
emploi industriel menacé
quelle belle déclaration en sarthe vous
voilà confrontés à des travaux pratiques
c'est le moment de passer des intentions
aux actes
dans quelques jours le couperet
définitive du tribunal de commerce de
nanterre devrait tomber ce sont près de
900 emplois industriels des sites
arjowiggins de saint-mars-la-brière et
bessé sur braye en sarthe qui pourrait
être rayé d'un trait de plume mais aussi
autant d'emplois de sous traitants ce
drame économique est un drame humain
pour plusieurs centaines de familles de
salariés celle de l' usine de bessé sur
braye notamment territoire à la limite
de la sarthe et du loir-et-cher vivent
dans un secteur extrêmement défavorisés
sur le plan industriel que leur restera
t-il l'état ne peut pas abandonner les
salariés d'arjowiggins à leur sort ne
serait ce que par ça parce que sa
responsabilité est dans ce dossier toute
particulière en effet l'état au travers
de la bpi a été associés à la
gouvernance de l'entreprise comme
actionnaire principal de sa maison mère
sequana au vu de la situation actuelle
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il a singulièrement manqué de
clairvoyance la situation exceptionnelle
nous attendons monsieur le ministre un
traitement exceptionnel
la présidente de la région des pays de
la loire christelle morançais prête à
engager sa collectivité pour contribuer
au sauvetage de cette industrie et des
emplois qui y sont attachés quelles
initiatives comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre de manière urgente pour
accompagner la région et pour que votre
priorité affichée de sauver les emplois
industriels soit dans la sarthe une
réalité comment entendez vous prendre en
compte le caractère exceptionnel du
dossier arjowiggins
pour vous répondre la parole et ses
critères établis auprès du ministre
d'économie et des finances afin
d'accompagner une hache-- mais la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vogel vous m'interrogez sur la
situation des sites d'arjowiggins deux
sites en sarthe un site dans l'aisne je
veux rappeler ici que l'état a travaillé
toute l'année 2018 et une reprise
globale de ces trois sites qui n'a
malheureusement pas vu le jour suite à
un contentieux prononcée par une cour
britannique qui faisait peser un
contentieux de 100 millions d'euros sur
le repreneur s'il reprenait dans les
circonstances le site
nous avons donc repris le dossier début
janvier suite à la au placement en
redressement judiciaire des trois sites
c'est grâce à l'état que la
l'exploitation a pu se poursuivre c'est
grâce également à l'état que plusieurs
repreneurs ont présenté un dossier sur
le site de château thierry sur le site
de loups bourré et vous le savez un
repreneur avait présenté un dossier sur
les trois sites
mercredi dernier ce repreneur a indiqué
qu'il n'était pas en mesure de
rassembler l'ensemble de l'argent pour
le mois d'avril pour la reprise des
trois sites
nous avons donc recommencer le travail
jeudi vendredi samedi dimanche lundi
mardi pour trouver une solution
main dans la main avec madame laurence
et puisque vous l'avez bien dit l'argent
public est aujourd'hui réunies pour
faire face à cette reprise
nous sommes aux côtés des salariés aux
côtés des organisations syndicales pour
trouver une solution
il reste 20 millions d'argent à trouver
20 millions d'argent privé et là c'est
beaucoup plus difficile et cet argent ne
pourra pas faire l'objet d'une garantie
de l'état ce sont les règles du jeu je
veux dire ici que l'état n'a pas à
rougir du travail qu'il fait sur les
dossiers de reprise sociétés en
difficulté dans trois cas sur quatre
nous trouvons une solution et j'aurais
été ravi que vos matériaux juillet sur
la situation d'arc par exemple 5000
emplois dans les hauts de france pour
lequel nous venons de trouver une
solution
aujourd'hui c'est un fait l'industrie
créé plus d'emplois qu'elle n'en détruit
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
joël labbé pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président la question
et pour monsieur didier au ministre de
l'agriculture
le marché bio se développe à un rythme
important ces dernières années et cela
va continuer toujours plus
d'agriculteurs adopte ce mode de
production qui répond aux attentes de
nos concitoyens et contribuer à la
préservation de la santé humaine de
l'environnement de la biodiversité et de
l'emploi aussi dans un entretien accordé
récemment à la fp monsieur le ministre
vous avez salué cette évolution tout en
appelant parallèlement à ne pas
industrialisés la bio tout comme les
acteurs historiques de la bio je me
réjouis de cette prise de position de
votre part qui ne me surprend pas mais
j'attends cependant de savoir si ces
déclarations seront suivis d'actes
politique fort et immédiat le 3 avril
prochain votre gouvernement sera appelé
à se prononcer au sein du comité
national des arts et cultures
biologiques sur la question de la
production en bio de fruits et légumes
sous serres chauffées
l'enjeu de cet arbitrage est d'interdire
le label bio aux légumes produits à
contre-saison tels que les tomates en
hiver les autres états européens ont
cadre encore très peu ces pratiques et
c'est donc à la france d'envoyer un
signal fort en montrant l'exemple et en
défendant cet encadrement auprès de
l'union européenne
cet arbitrage déjà reporté une fois ne
cela ne saurait l'être à nouveau
selon l'ademe la culture sous serre
chauffée mais près de dix fois plus de
co2 qu'une production respectant les
cycles naturels
alors ma question est simple et directe
monsieur le ministre comptez vous
soutenir l'interdiction du chauffage des
serres pour la production à
contre-saison de légumes labellisés bio
je remercie qu'on vous répondre
la parole est à mme schmid d'agriculture
de l'alimentation dire si le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur la baie
vous avez votre question est simple mais
les pas simple du tout votre question
elle est même très compliqué cela
concerne d'abord aujourd'hui 38
entreprises pour 9500 tonnes de produits
le comité de réglementation de la
culture biologique
il travaille depuis des années un comité
national de l'agriculture biologique
s'est réduit en octobre n'a pas pu
trancher
il doit subir de 3 avril comme il ne
pourra pas tranché il sera reporté en
juillet et c'est ça le sujet parce que
l'alternative est ce un beau dit il faut
interdire
est ce que la france voit sûr transposer
ou pas aujourd'hui attendait au jour
aujourd'hui l'agriculture biologique et
une demande forte de nos concitoyens il
faut la soutenir l'agriculture
biologique en serre existe nous devons
la soutenir
est ce qu'il faut elle existe est-ce
qu'il faut chauffer les serres avec dédé
d'énergies fossiles ou fioul la réponse
est non est ce que nous devons autorisé
la possibilité de chauffer des serres
avec des panneaux photovoltaïques avec
des énergies renouvelables c'est la
discussion qui est sur la table dans
lequel le monde agricole et l'ensemble
de la pression ne s'est pas mis d'accord
c'est pour laisser la raison pour
laquelle nous devons encore en discuter
pour trouver une position de compromis
je pense que nous sommes nous devons
faire attention à deux choses 1 les sur
transposition deuxièmement à ne pas nous
mettre en difficulté économique par
rapport à d'autres pays mais surtout le
la france est un pays leader dans
l'agriculture biologique et de devons
continuer à l'assumer
évidemment cultiver des légumes et des
fruits hors saison n'est pas une réalité
de ce que nous devons faire dans le
cadre de l'agro écologie
c'est là à présent pour laquelle j'ai
répondu je n'étais pas favorable à
l'agriculture industrielle biologique
c'est la position du gouvernement
mais je crois que pour la sagesse et
afin de répondre tranquillement à votre
question le président du comité national
et futurs biologique va proposer qu'il y
encore trois mois de réflexion afin de
faire rapprocher les points de vue je
vous remercie
je l'avais je dois vous dire monsieur le
ministre c'est désolant d'encore devoir
reporter on sait que ce sont des
industriels qui veulent s'approprier le
marché du bio alors que pour nos
concitoyens notre notre agriculture bio
doit être exigeant conclu en bio deux
saisons une bio local et une bio qui
reste en lien avec le sol je vous
remercie
merci à parler notre collègue jean
françois rapin pour le groupe l'est
républicain
le seul président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur françois
de rugy ce week-end dans la région de
france à l'initiative de son président
xavier bertrand une grande manifestation
de nettoyage du territoire qualifié
haute france propre a connu un réel
succès rassemblant 50 mille de nos
concitoyens sur toute la région
cette manifestation volontaire solidaire
et écologique a malheureusement été
entaché par une police ou par une
pollution d'origine maritime survenue
quelques jours auparavant sur le
littoral du nord du pas de calais ainsi
que de la somme cette pollution a été
minimisée dans les mois à la suite de
l'événement au large des côtes de
charente maritime était fort dramatique
et inquiétant la paraffine qui est en
cause provoque ce désordre régulièrement
sur nos plages
deux à trois fois par an depuis déjà
plusieurs années ceci est dû et nous le
savons tous au nettoyage au nettoyage
des cuves 2 chimiquiers madame la
ministre
la semaine dernière le gouvernement fut
interpellé au sujet du grande des
américains
à cette occasion il a été déclaré que
des propositions seraient faites au
niveau européen pour renforcer la
sécurité et la réglementation
il y a donc urgence quel recours
technique et judiciaire
comptez vous engager afin de pénaliser
les contrevenants au maintien de la
biodiversité de l'un des détroits les
plus fréquentés du monde
et surtout notre littoral merci pour
vous répondre
l'apparent les et la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre d'état lida
transition écologique et solidaire
wargon vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
le sénat les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs rapin vous avez raison de nous
alerter sur cet épisode de pollution à
la paraffine qui a touché les côtes
picarde
effectivement nous avons été alertés le
lundi 18 mars sur l'existence de
dizaines de boulettes de paraffine qui
ont touché les côtes depuis fort mahon
dans la somme jusqu'à marck en calaisis
dans le pas de calais et ses
associations ce mot se sont mobilisés
dès le week end du 16 et du 17 mars pour
nettoyer les plages
je voudrais d'ailleurs salué la
mobilisation des associations des
communes et des citoyens sachant que
environ 200 litres de paraffine ont pu
être récupérés dans cette opération de
nettoyage
l'état s'est immédiatement mobilisé bien
sûr les directions départementales des
territoires et de la mer
de la somme et du pas de calais ont
effectué des prélèvements effet les
analyses toxicologiques de ces
prélèvements qui sont rassurantes
pas de risque particulier pas de danger
d'intoxication les préfectures ont par
ailleurs repassé les consignes de
protection habituelle
attention à ne pas manipuler lorsqu on
nettoie les plages la paraffine à mains
nues il faut des gants des lunettes et
des équipements de protection pour
toutes les consignes de sécurité
mais la question que vous posez c'est la
question des causes et notre capacité à
agir des causes vous l'avez dit sont
connus ce sont des navires qui
lorsqu'ils circulent dans les couloirs
de navigation effectué des rejets au
moment des nettoyages de fond de cuve
serre ges sont dans certains cas
autorisés à l'heure actuelle par
l'organisation maritime internationale
bien sûr avec des plafonds et sous
certaines conditions
cette situation n'est pas satisfaisante
dès lors deux actions sont engagés
d'abord une enquête en cours de la
direction des affaires maritimes pour
déterminer la cause et bien sûr engager
les poursuites si le navire en question
est identifié et ensuite plus
globalement avec le centre de lutte
contre la pollution maritime nous nous
mobiliserons pour porter ce sujet au
plan communautaire comme au plan
international
monsieur rappaz merci madame la ministre
mais je pense qu'il faut pénaliser
beaucoup plus fort ces actions et je
vais vous soumettre une idée finalement
puisque il semble qu'on édifie des
difficultés à financer la résilience et
la protection du trait de côte il serait
un terrain intéressant de prendre une
partie de la pénalisation et des
financements et des financements liés à
la pénalisation pour rassurer ce
problème de la de la résilience donc
madame la ministre il faut agir il faut
agir et vite
merci d'en parler notre collègue samia
ghali pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
messieurs les ministres ce dimanche à 14
heures les habitants du quartier de la
bricarde ont été pris en otages des feux
croisés de kalachnikov d'un commando
d'une dizaine d'hommes encagoulés
porteurs de brassards de police est
sorti de trois véhicules dont certains
étaient dotés de gyrophares alerter
alerté par des mamans hurlantes de peur
face à ces scènes de guerre j'ai été
saisi d'un mélange de colère colère et
d'indignation trois quarts d'heure c'est
le temps qu'il a fallu aux forces de
l'ordre pour arriver sur place
pendant ce temps les habitants parmi eux
des enfants essayé d'échapper
malheureusement au bal de ces armes de
guerre à travers ses mots messieurs les
ministres se sont tout simplement la
parole des habitants que je représente
ici au sénat que sont devenues les
promesses de la reconquête des zones de
non droit où le plus jamais ça que le
ministre gérard collomb à la suite de la
tacc d'avis sur il ya un an avait dit
aux avis aux habitants de la busserine
l' approche globale mise en place en
2012 est conduite par vous même monsieur
ménez a porté ses fruits mais elle a été
abandonné laissant à la place à la
recrudescence des trafics et à la
veuille ans qui les accompagnent parce
que la république doit assurer aux
citoyens le même droit à la sécurité et
des champs elysées à la bricarde
messieurs les ministres je vous demande
de mettre en place un comité
interministériel de la sécurité pour
marseille d'instaurer lé approche
globale de doter marseille de deux cents
policiers supplémentaires ainsi que des
crs
merci
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
c'est le rendu n'est je suis le préfet
je suis en mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à l'ab la sénatrice samia
ghali
d'abord vous comprendrez que nous le
gouvernement partage les mois bien
évidemment des populations des quartiers
marseillaise suite à la grave incident
que vous avez rappelé qui s'est déroulé
donc à la cité de la bricarde comme
quinze jours avant nous avions eu un
nouveau règlement de comptes à la
busserine vous dire vous avez raison de
le souligner que sous le quinquennat
précédent une action résolue avaient été
engagées mais cette action nous l'avons
poursuivi
ça s'appelait l' approche globale entre
2012 et 2017
et cette action nous l'avons continuer
je vous rappelle qu'elle repose sur deux
piliers d'abord une présence de voie
publique de policiers renforcés
c'est ce que nous avons fait dans le cas
de la politique des quartiers de
reconquête républicaine avec une
augmentation des effectifs qui ont
permis d'augmenter les bacs d'augmenter
lé groupe de sécurité de proximité
les brigades spécialisées de terrain qui
rayonne sur les quartiers marseillais
qui nouent des partenariats et nous les
avons augmentés ils sont présents comme
sont présentes les unités de forces
mobiles chaque fois que nous le pouvons
et à la bricarde c'est la quatrième cité
marseillaise en temps de présence de ces
forces mobiles mais comme vous le savez
aussi nous menons une action en
profondeur
moins visible par les habitants des
quartiers mais qui est importante c'est
une action de démantèlement des trafics
de stupéfiants et elle n'a jamais cessé
elle se déroule dans le cadre d'une
coordination renforcée entre tous les
services de police qui a permis de
démanteler 32 réseaux en profondeur en
2018 et nous avons associé depuis peu le
service des douanes
et cette année ce sont les gendarmes qui
seront associés également parce que les
réseaux à marseille se ramifie sur
l'ensemble des bouches du rhône haussier
donc nous serons présents dans cette
action croyez bien que nous allons
poursuivre avec beaucoup de
détermination cette politique de
présence renforcée de démantèlement des
trafics de prévention aussi des
règlements de compte ce sont 7
règlements de comptes qui ont été
déjouées en 2018 cette action nous
allons la poursuivre avec beaucoup de
détermination
vous connaissez l'attachement que je
porte personnellement à la ville de
marseille et croyez bien que tout sera
fait pour que cessent les scènes telles
que celles que nous avons vécues que
vous avez décrite avec une émotion que
nous percevons que je perçois et que
bien évidemment nous partageons et j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour saluer le
courage et la détermination des
policiers marseillais qui chaque jour
lutte résolument contre les trafics
merci
madame galli il vous reste
monsieur le ministre il s'agit là bon je
veux juste dire que ces enfants qui ont
vécu cette scène le lendemain sont allés
à l'école et ce qu'ils ont vécu c'est
pas le jeu vidéo le plus violent mais
c'est tout simplement la réalité de leur
vie au quotidien
merci à parler comme collègue claudine
kaufmann pour le sénateur n'appartenant
aucun gros vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
le ministre des solidarités de la santé
lorsqu'emmanuel macron était candidat à
la présidence de la france
il ne sait c'est de souligner
l'impérieuse nécessité de faire montre
d'une transparence totale quant aux
affaires publiques
pourtant cette déclaration d'intention
n'est pas toujours suivi d'effet
lorsqu'une question susceptible de
mettre le gouvernement
lorsqu'une question est susceptible de
mettre le gouvernement en difficulté
ainsi la semaine dernière dans cet
hémicycle votre secrétaire d'état adrien
taquet a refusé de répondre clairement
lorsqu'il fut interpellé par notre
collègue nathalie goulet au sujet de la
fraude massive sur les cartes vitale je
rappelle ici que le nombre de numéros
d'inscription répertoire varient de 17 à
plus de 100 millions
cet écart est pour le moins déconcertant
par ailleurs le service administratif
national d'immatriculation des assurés
qui appartient à l'un de vos propres
services elle estime qu 1,8 million de
ces numéros ont été attribués suite à
l'utilisation de faux documents
nous sommes en droit de connaître le
nombre total ainsi que le nombre de ceux
qui sont encore actifs
je souhaite que vous nous préciser le
nombre de numéros d'inscription
répertoire qui ont été attribués à des
étrangers résidant en france
en effet l'opacité singulière que vous
persistez entretenir sciemment nous
interpelle si j'attends une réponse
précise
je désire surtout que vous m'indiquer
quelles sont les mesures que vous
envisagez de prendre afin de remédier à
la fraude massive sur les utilisations
de la carte vitale
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole était
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités et de la sorte est valable
du boss merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice votre interrogation
porte sur le sujet des fraudes aux
prestations qui seraient commises à
cause du numéro de sécu social ce qu'on
appelle le nir attribuées sur la base de
faux documents des assurés sociaux nés
hors de france sait si ces chiffres sont
souvent relayés et on comprend
l'inquiétude qu'ils peuvent susciter
tant le préjudice subi estimé serait
important la ministre mme labuzan a
rapidement demandé à ce que des données
soient examinées au regard des
compléments qui ont été apportées je
peux vous dire qu'il ne correspond en
rien à la réalité
il me semble par conséquent nécessaire
de rétablir les faits il serait en effet
regrettable que les fausses informations
amènent certains de nos concitoyens à
stigmatiser les personnes nées à
l'étranger en les associant des
fraudeurs ou à imaginer que les
prestations de cycle sociales sont
versées sans aucun contrôle et donc
sujette un phénomène massif de fraude
6,18 millions de niro ont bien été
attribuée est rassuré le cadet fraude
représenterait tout au +0 2% des
situations en 2017
il apparaît que l'écart entre le taux
qui a été médiatisé et la réalité tient
une mauvaise compréhension des données
observées le tord prix a été extrapolée
à partir des résultats intermédiaires
d'une campagne de contrôle interne qui
visait à évaluer la conformité des
pièces justificatives acceptée par le
service administratif national
d'immatriculer d assurer au cours du
processus d'attribution d'un numéro
d'inscription répertoire il s'agit donc
pas de fraude avérée puisque les assurés
dont les pièces présentaient des
anomalies ont été recontacté et ont pu
apporter des pièces justificatives
complémentaires dans la plupart des cas
il n'y avait pas d'intention de fraude
et pourrait assurer une mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle sur la
fraude à l'obtention de numéro de strip
sociale présidée par le rapporteur
général est en cours depuis deux mois
elle devrait rendre les premières
conclusions dans les semaines qui
viennent
permettez moi avant de conclure
d'ajouter deux remarques d'ordre général
sur l'environnement de contrôle du
versement des prestations
le premier est qu'un numéro
d'inscription ne permet pas à lui seul
de bénéficier de prestations qui
nécessite la production de pièces
justificatives spécifiques à chaque
situation qui viennent en complément de
densification de la personne le second
est
vision mais connaît l'importance des
dispositifs de contrôle à l'oeuvre dans
l'organisme
l'organisme de ccld sociale et
dispositifs de maîtrise des risques sont
extrêmement complet puisque ils sont
certifiés depuis 2013 merci madame
couronne une fois encore votre refus de
répondre clairement à une question
simple les zones comme une caution
apportée aux fraudeurs
d'autant que leurs méfaits portent sur
des sommes considérables nos
compatriotes dont vous avez accru la
pression fiscale apprécieront
certainement nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le 4 avril
devait suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 17h50 pour la suite du projet
de loi d'orientation des mobilités la
séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement et vous l'avez
vu la sénatrice socialiste de marseille
samia ghali a posé une question sur un
nouvel épisode de violence dans les
quartiers nord de marseille puisque ce
week-end un commando armé de kalachnikov
a effectué des tirs d'intimidation dans
une cité des quartiers nord
tout cela ce devant les yeux des
habitants et des enfants de cette cité
la cité de la bricarde alors ça mais
ghali a réclamé le droit à la sécurité
que ce soit je cite sur les
champs-elysées ou dans les quartiers
nord de marseille
le secrétaire d'état au ministère de
l'intérieur laurent nyonnaise lui a
répondu en saluant l'action des briques
à des brigades mobiles dans ces
quartiers difficiles et puis en saluant
l'action des services pour démanteler
les réseaux de trafiquants de drogue
et puis cette séance a été marquée par
une question sur la crise industrielle
industriel pardon puisque 900 emplois
sont menacés dans les usines du goût du
groupe de papeterie arjowiggins dans la
sarthe et dans l'aisne le sénateur les
républicains de la sarthe jean pierre
vogel a accusé l'état d'avoir été un
mauvais gestionnaire dans ce dossier
puisqu'il était l'actionnaire principal
de la maison mère d'arjowiggins
la secrétaire d'état à l'économie agnès
pannier rue nager a assuré que l'état
faisait tout pour trouver un repreneur
et elle a informé les sénateurs qu'il
manquait 20 millions d'euros d'argent
privé pour sauver arjowiggins et puis
enfin une question sur la fiscalité avec
le sénateur les républicains laurent
duplomb qui a critiqué les ministres et
les cadres de la république en marche
qui proposait des hausses de taxes pour
sortir du grand débat national gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics a salué le bilan fiscal
du gouvernement qui selon l'insee lé
gouvernement qui a le plus baissé les
impôts dans les deux premières années
d'un quinquennat voilà jérôme pour les
temps forts de ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre et on va
revenir longuement sur cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
mais vous connaissez le principe on
retourne aussi régulièrement en salle
des conférences
etam justement vous êtes avec le
sénateur de loire atlantique
ronan dantec pour évoquer la liste en
marche aux européennes et oui la liste
intitulée renaissants vos tournées de
découvrir à
et trente premiers noms à les porter et
bien par là bientôt ex ministre des
affaires européennes nathalie l'oiseau
mais il ya aussi sur cette liste est
bien des personnes aussi diverses que
pascal canfin du wwf mais aussi et bien
l'ex président des jeunes agriculteurs
jérémy decerle que quel regard
portez-vous sur cette liste ronan dantec
c'est assez curieux à ce stade moi je
suis quand même surpris de la décision
de pascal canfin puisque lui-même avait
dit qu'il avait refusé le poste de
ministre après le départ de nicolas
hulot parce qu'il n'avait pas assez de
garanties et il se retrouve maintenant
numéro deux de cette liste aux
européennes et avec juste derrière un
défenseur de l'agriculture productiviste
donc lui même dit qu'il a obtenu des
garanties lesquels je n'en sais
effectivement rien donc on verra dans
les prochaines semaines notamment à la
fin du grand débat s'il ya une mutation
inverse la transition écologique dans
les politiques publiques portées par ce
gouvernement mais à ce jour moi j'avoue
surtout ma ma grande surprise grande
surprise ça vous des soir un petit peu
de la part de cubains qui a toujours
porté la voix de l'écologie moi je porte
pas jamais de jugement sur les choix
politiques des uns et des autres les
choix politiques on les fait en
conscience
il a peut-être des éléments que je n'ai
pas et que nous découvrirons dans les
prochaines semaines unique en tout cas à
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles ils
intègrent cette si c'est parce que
l'écologie compte parmi réellement les
priorités de est bien de cette campagne
pour la république en marche alors ce
qui est certain c'est qu'avec la
présence de pascal canfin en deux on
voit bien que l'écologie aujourd'hui est
un élément structurant du débat
politique en france
ça c'est extrêmement important mais ça
ne peut pas être qu'un élément du débat
ça doit être surtout un élément des
politiques publiques c'est à dire faire
d'une priorité notamment financières et
pascal canfin est beaucoup intervenu là
dessus faire de l'écologie est une des
grandes priorités financières des
politiques publiques et de ce
gouvernement c'est là dessus qu'on
l'attend nous on a fait beaucoup de
propositions
nous en avons encore porté avec le
collectif urgence climatique des
sénateurs il y a quelques jours nous
emporter dans le grand débat sur le
soutien aux collectivités sur le
déplafonnement du 1.2 qui corsètent
aujourd'hui les collectivités dans leurs
investissements
est-ce que sur tous ces points il a
obtenu quelque chose des avancées
notables effectivement moi je n'en sais
strictement rien
un mot enfin sur le fait que les
écologistes et bien ils partent tout de
même en ordre dispersé sur cette
campagne des européennes vous le
regrettez il ya plus trop de cohérence
dans le mouvement écologiste aujourd'hui
moi je crois qu'on vient un moment où
l'écologie étant devenu un des éléments
structurants du débat politique
elle se décline sur plusieurs
sensibilités politiques
je crois je crois que c'est un moment un
peu inévitable sur ce moment là il y
aura un avant et un après européenne moi
je crois qu'au lendemain des européennes
il faudra se remettre autour de la table
revenir sur cette question puisque moi
je suis un écologiste de gauche est
assumé à gauche du positionnement de la
campagne yannick jadot même si c'est
l'offre politique qui me semble toujours
l'appeler la plus proche et que je
soutiens et et créer une dynamique mais
à mon avis cette dynamique aujourd'hui
se créera plus tôt après les élections
européennes et partira des territoires
et pas des appareils nationaux et bien
merci beaucoup rendant d'ataq d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et je vois non
loin de vous et bien la ministre des
transports
elisabeth bornes bonjour merci beaucoup
je vais devenir répondre à nos questions
son plateau de public sénat pourra
travailler sur cette loi mobilité dans
l'examen est en cours ici au sénat
depuis déjà la semaine dernière et tout
à l'heure et bien les sénateurs ont
remis de la flexibilité sur les 80 km
heure pour eux et bien il faut donner
plutôt la possibilité aux présidents de
départements aux préfets de pouvoirs à
la 90 km à votre réaction
écoutez enfin moi je voudrais d'abord me
féliciter de façon générale de la
qualité du travail qui est mené avec le
sénat depuis maintenant une semaine je
pense que l'axé en première lecture au
sénat qui est en première lecture au
sénat je pense que c'est effectivement
une bonne chose parce que le sénat a
bien perçu tous les enjeux en termes
d'équilibré des territoires que porte
cette loi je pense que chacun est aussi
conscient de la tente très forte de nos
concitoyens pour qu'on n'ait plus de
réponses en termes de mobilité des
réponses plus équilibrée sur le
territoire qu'on sache aussi proposées
partout des alternatives à la voiture
donc on mène un travail de qualité avec
les sénateurs et je m'en réjouis
alors en effet 180 kilos mais damas un
débat sur le 80 km heure vous savez le
gouvernement a annoncé dès le départ
qu'ils auraient
une évaluation de ce dispositif dont on
peut déjà voilà dont on peut déjà noter
qu'il a sauvé des vies au cours de
l'année 2018 donc les sénateurs ont
souhaité sans attendre cette évaluation
permet des adaptations locales du
dispositif imaginé que ça ne s'est pas
fait avec l'avis favorable du
gouvernement
moi j'entends bien dans le débat les
attentes qui sont formulées président de
la république a eu l'occasion de dire à
dicter qui peut y avoir plus de
souplesse réfléchir à des adaptations
tout comme le premier ministre avait
indiqué qu' on aurait une évaluation
donc voilà laissons les choses venir
laissant le débat se termine et les
enseignements en être tirées
l'évaluation se faire et je pense que
c'est ça la bonne façon de procéder
également il va y avoir et bien des
débats prochainement sur la question du
forfait mobilité que prévoit le
gouvernement en la matière ça va
remplacer les indemnités kilométriques
qui existe aujourd'hui et notamment pour
les personnes qui préfèrent prendre le
vélo pour se rendre à leur travail
alors ce forfait mobilité il vise à
répondre à une injustice qui est aussi
perçu par beaucoup de nos concitoyens
quand vous êtes dans une grande ville
vous avez des transports en commun et
votre employeur rembourse 50 % de
l'abonnement
quand vous êtes dans des zones moins
denses des villes moyennes par exemple
ou des petites villes vous n'avez pas
nécessairement de transport en commun et
vous n'êtes pas accompagné par votre
employeur donc à une sorte de double
peine
forfait mobilité il vise effectivement à
permettre à l'employeur de verser
jusqu'à 400 euros par an aujourd'hui
voilà sans charges sociales sans
fiscalité pour ceux qui font du
covoiturage et du vélo et il vise aussi
être effectivement plus simple que
l'indemnité kilométrique vélo qui s'est
mis en place dans quelques entreprises
quelques collectivités mais qui est
quand même un dispositif compliqué donc
ce forfait mobilité il vise à répondre à
cet objectif de mieux accompagner tous
ceux qui n'ont pas nécessairement accès
aux transports en commun et vous savez
ce forfait avec une indemnité de
transport vous y est opposée par leur
jeu je voudrais surtout souligner que
moi je souhaite qu'on aille plus loin et
j'entends beaucoup de français qui
souhaite être accompagné mieux
accompagner dans leur trajet domicile
travail
donc on a une discussion avec les
partenaires sociaux notamment les
employeurs pour voir dans quelle mesure
ce forfait peut être plus systématique
et puis comment on peut prendre en
compte également
situation des salariés qui n'ont pas
d'alternative à la voiture individuelle
et tous ces sujets sont dans la
discussion dont la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux et donc on aura
l'occasion de finaliser le dispositif
dans les prochaines semaines merci
beaucoup elisabeth bande d'avoir répondu
à mes questions je vous laisse regagner
la séance ou 7 poursuit donc l'examen de
la loi l'homme d'orientation des
mobilités merci beaucoup ta mais j'en
profite pour accueillir sur le plateau
emmanuel capus bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur les indépendants du maine et
loire et délégué national d'agir on va
évoquer ces questions d'actualité mais
actualité c'est la présentation
aujourd'hui de la liste en marche pour
les européennes et agir dont vous êtes
délégué national ee présents sur cette
liste avec notamment quelqu'un qu'on
connaît bien ici la sénatrice fabienne
keller c'est une bonne chose pour vous
qu agir soit présent sur cette liste
c'est un choix que nous avons fait qu'on
a réfléchi qu'on a clairement posé c'est
de faire une liste de rassemblement avec
en marche avec le modem avec les
radicaux de participer à une grande
liste de rassemblement
moi j'étais membre de la commission
nationale d'investiture on n'avait fait
aussi le choix d'un certain nombre de
candidats qu'on a proposé à en marche et
les deux premiers candidats
effectivement que nous avons proposées
c'était fabienne keller et xavier
fournier
je constate effectivement qui sont dans
les 30 premiers de cette liste fabienne
keller qui en septième position qui est
normalement une position éligible pour
ces élections européennes alors mais
dans cette liste en marche
il ya un peu de tout ça va des
écologistes et ancien journaliste un
ancien président des jeunes agriculteurs
gris culteurs est ce que c'est un
melting-pot qui finalement peut créer
une alchimie ça je ne sais pas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'effectivement au delà
des partis politiques qui ont fait
alliance dans cette campagne il ya
beaucoup de sociétés civiles et c'était
sont manifestement un souhait du
président de la république
je ne sais pas si l'alchimie va prendre
ce qui est certain c'est que le point
commun c'est manifestement un
attachement à la politique européenne
et ça c'est ça c'est positif shaw
effectivement aussi positif que les
jeunes agriculture soit représentée est
très bien représentée en numéro 4 avec
jérémy de cercle c'est un excellent
signe donné
l'agriculture en france il va pouvoir
mettre d'accord sur la question du
glyphosate jérémy de cercle avec pascal
canfin qui est lui deuxième la question
du glyphosate c'est bien l'europe qui va
régler cette question
c'est le en même temps présidentiel je
pense alors justement ce en même temps
présidentiel
emmanuel macron il accueillait
aujourd'hui à l'élysée le président
chinois le président chinois qui est
ensuite venu au sénat il a il s'est
entretenu avec le président larcher et
ce sujet de la chine il a été évoqué
lors de ces questions d'actualité il ya
une question et c'est jean baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état qui a répondu
on va l'écouter je vous fait réagir
juste après après un peu plus de deux
jours cette visite a été empreinte de
respect d'amitié sans pour autant
laisser cours à la naïveté c'est une
réussite pour la relation bilatérale
avec une commande de 300 airbus mais
également le renforcement de la
coopération culturelle de la mobilité de
nos jeunes de la formation
professionnelle ou des échanges
linguistiques et le président de la
république a également rappelé les
préoccupations qui sont les nôtres et
celle de l'europe sur la question des
droits fondamentaux
ce matin avait lieu d'ailleurs un moment
très important un moment où s'agissant
de rénover le multilatéralisme qui vous
le savez parfois battus en brèche par
certaines puissances et bien l'europe
était présente à travers le président de
la commission européenne à travers la
chancelière merkel le président de la
république mn macron aux côtés du
président chi pour affirmer un certain
nombre est bien d'engagement pour que ce
multilatéralisme soit toujours vivace
emmanuel capus c'est une réponse
européenne qu'il faut face à l'hégémonie
la tentation hégémonique de la chine la
chine sait c'est un continent en fait
donc c'est un partenaire incontournable
de l'europe et de la france
le ministre a bien fait de rappeler
qu'on a une relation particulière depuis
général de gaulle avec la chine
ça c'est bien et en même temps on voit
bien on est en visite d'état
donc ils n'osent pas dire des mots qui
fâchent la question de joël guerriau été
beaucoup plus pointues elles
concernaient les axes agesilas
sur la 5g par warwick et là dessus
j'espère que c'est uniquement parce
qu'on est en visite d'état et que le
ministre a pas voulu faire de clash mais
on a dû à la quasi à une vraie question
est une vraie question
il ya une vraie question avec les
pouvoirs qui sont forts et si on veut
être respecté il faut être fort aussi il
faut dénoncer ce qui n'est pas
acceptable la semaine dernière moi
j'avais posé une question sur nasrin
sotoudeh qui est emprisonné en inde
le ministre yang a été très clair il
avait dit c'est pas parce qu on a
négocié un accord avec l'inde et qu'on
les soutient sur le sur le nucléaire
qu'on doit ces savoirs partagés de dire
le pape a tort de se réjouir les choses
on va pense qu'il faut qu'on dise les
choses aussi avec la chine sur cette
question de la visite du président
chinois on va tout de suite aller en
salle des conférences du sénat puisque
tam vous êtes avec jean visait le
président les républicains de la
commission des affaires européennes du
sénat
oui jean bizet vous avez assez tout à
l'heure à la visite de chez jean ping
qui étaient ici au sénat il ya quelques
minutes
quel regard portez-vous et bien sur le
fait qu'il faut il une véritable réponse
unie européenne c'est ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron ce matin face et bien
aux chinois c'est une bonne chose
de toute façon c c'est essentiel et ça
fait partie de l'architecturé du
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
puisque les accords de libre échange
sont une compétence exclusive de l'union
européenne donc tout discours je dirais
nationale si je puis dire est
inapproprié et justement ce que l'on
voit c'est que lâchés elle tente un
petit peu de deux fractures et l'union
européenne
par sa politique d'investissements
attendre de jouer une petite des
divisions entre les pays européens
aujourd'hui
oui l attaque entre guillemets si je
puis dire les maillons faibles notamment
l'italie et donc à charge pour nous de
réagir je dirai clairement c'est la
raison pour laquelle et je suis un peu
surpris de la réaction italienne près il
ya 18 mois
l'italie l'allemagne et la france se
sont mis d'accord pour je dirais proposé
au 28
28 à l'époque ce qu'on appelle un
règlement sur les investissements
directs étrangers permettant d'éviter
justement la plantation en chine sur des
entreprises stratégiques et biens de
capitaux chinois ont parlé de
marie-france à l'instant justement de
voir que vous avez vous êtes entretenu
ce matin avec le président de huawei
france qu est il ressorti et de votre
entretien
assurément huawei a une avance
technologique très nette par rapport à
ses concurrents européens ou aux
américains
ceci étant je leur ai clairement dit que
nous n'étions pas neige qu'il y avait
bien évidemment des portes dérobées
pourrait coûter entre guillemets
l'europe et que
nous n'étions absolument pas fermé sur
cette avance technologique mais nous
serions extrêmement sourcilleux sur ce
qu'on appelle le respect des données au
travers du rgp des et de ses portes
dérobées
eh bien merci beaucoup jean bizet
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup tam emmanuel capus on va
évoquer un sujet de cette séance de
questions d'actualité c'est plutôt un
non sujet puisque il n'y a pas eu de
réponse d'edouard philippe qui était
attendu pour son retour au sénat puisque
je le rappelle la semaine dernière il
avait boycotté cette séance de questions
d'actualité
tweet finalement aux rapports benalla et
à la transmission à la justice par le
bureau du sénat des cas des proches
conseillers l'elysée c'est une volonté
d'apaisement entre le sénat et
l'exécutif il n'y a pas une question de
président de groupe donc c'est normal
que le premier ministre ait pas répondu
au delà de ça moi c'est vrai que je
m'étais félicité la semaine dernière du
fait qu'on saisisse le parquet pour les
mensonges de monsieur b d'alan monsieur
crasse j'avais manifesté mon regret
profond du fait que la majorité du
bureau du sénat
transmettre au parquet le cas des trois
hauts fonctionnaires qui manifestement
n'ont pas menti pour des cadres
d'incohérences et de contradictions ne
sais pas si ça valait la peine
ça jette un voile n'a soupçon de
politique politicienne
d'instrumentalisation de la justice par
le politique qui m'apparaît c'est pas
utile à un moment où on a besoin d'un
politique d'une politique fort d'un
exécutif fort et d'une confiance entre
effectivement le gouvernement et les
assemblées
merci beaucoup emmanuel capus d'avoir
été notre invité pour débriefer cette
séance d'initiation d'actualité au
gouvernement
c'est déjà la fin de cette édition merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi à 18h30 vous
retrouvez rebecca fitoussi et son
émission on va plus loin
excellente suite des programmes sur
public sénat
[Musique]